[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti
di già
[Applauso]
Grazie per volermi dedicare oggi il
vostro tempo per me è un po' strano
essere qui perché quando mi hanno
invitato a tenere questo the Talk è la
prima cosa che ho pensato ho detto ma io
cosa c'entro Non ho nulla di così altro
da raccontare poi mi hanno detto che la
parola chiave era rumore e allora detto
ma forse lascio proprio perdere perché
cosa mi invento a quel punto però ho
iniziato a riflettere e mi sono chiesto
cosa avrei potuto dirvi oggi
Ripensando alla parola rumore e al
significato di quella parola in quel
momento ho capito che l'unica cosa che
avrei potuto fare era quella di
raccontare la mia storia l'unica storia
che conosco quella che mi porta qui oggi
davanti a voi
quando ripercorri la tua storia fai
sempre un buon viaggio introspettivo
ripensi a chi sei stato ma lo fai
guardandoti con gli occhi di oggi con la
consapevolezza che negli anni hai
raggiunto come quindi è come se ti
guardassi per la prima volta
non so se ci avete provato fatelo
tornate a casa perché è una figata
colossale Io l'ho fatto negli scorsi
anni nel mio percorso di vita e l'ho
rifatto nelle scorse settimane proprio
perché oggi volevo essere qui E lì ho
realizzato come per tutta la prima parte
della mia vita io abbia intenzionalmente
rifiutato il rumore preferendo sempre il
silenzio il mio di silenzio
Questo sono io
a 4 anni Forse qui Seduto da qualche
parte
ero chiuso totalmente nella mia
timidezza e sapete mi rifiutavo spesso
di giocare con gli altri bambini un po'
un bambino atipico Perché Quale bambino
si rifiuta di giocare quando a quattro
anni sapete sono stato un bambino un
adolescente cresciuto con un grandissimo
senso di inadeguatezza ho sempre pensato
di non essere sufficientemente alto
sufficientemente estroverso intelligente
o simpatico e tutte quelle robe lì
Ma se ci ripenso Oggi dico vabbè non
sono poi così speciali tutti ci siamo
sentiti non abbastanza quando eravamo
adolescenti adolescenti e spesso quelle
insicurezze ce le portiamo ancora oggi
no io però ho sempre pensato di non
essere abbastanza per poter sognare di
fare qualcosa di più per poter inseguire
un sogno e provare a realizzarlo da solo
anche se in quel momento non sapevo
nemmeno quale fosse il mio sogno dove
volevo andare che sogno volevo
rincorrere e probabilmente per questo
motivo che inseguivo il silenzio anche
dopo quando stavo crescendo perché quel
silenzio mi permetteva di sparire
quasi provando a diventare un po' l'Uomo
Invisibile no Quando sei invisibile non
devi confrontarti con nessuno con
nessuna sfida quindi pensi non hai
problemi dopo però realizzi che se
continui a nasconderti poi smettono di
guardarti di sentirti tutti anche le
persone che ti sono vicine e per me è
stato nel momento in cui non mi sono più
fatto vedere o sentire che mi sono
sentito come se non esistessi più come
se finalmente era lì l'Uomo Invisibile
davanti a me lo guardavo allo specchio e
quell'uomo ero io dopo mi hanno spiegato
che quella sensazione si chiama
repressione una parola che fa male
però arrivato a quel punto un giorno di
8 anni fa ho deciso di cambiare la mia
vita
di smettere di stare in silenzio e di
provare a inseguire le mie intuizioni
anche se non avevo idea di dove
potessero portarmi quelle intuizioni
l'ho fatto senza paura ma con la
consapevolezza che volevo farmi sentire
anche urlando se fosse stato necessario
un giorno di otto anni fa ho deciso di
lasciare il lavoro da giornalista che mi
frustrava tremendamente per inseguire
quella che era una mia intuizione cioè
quella di provare a cavalcare la
rivoluzione dei social media lavorando
con una ragazza che era già affermata e
di successo ma che stava anche lei
lottando contro Chi pensava che non
fosse abbastanza e che non sarebbe
durata nel tempo
quella ragazza si chiamava Chiara
Ferragni si chiama ancora oggi Chiara
Ferragni in realtà
l'avevo conosciuta qualche anno prima io
facevo il giornalista in quel momento
lei era agli esordi alle sue prime
sfilate molto timida mi ricordo anch'io
molto timido e le mie colleghe
giornaliste del tempo mi consigliarono
di non mischiarmi alle blogger perché
tanto da lì a qualche mese sarebbero
sparite quindi perché perder tempo e
soprattutto loro si sentivano anche più
cool di chi iniziava questo mestiere in
quel momento e io sapete cosa ho fatto
non le ho ascoltate
ho dato retta solo al mio istinto che mi
diceva che quella ragazza molto gentile
che postava i suoi luxum Block fosse una
persona di talento è capace di
comunicare in un modo rivoluzionario un
modo che da lì a poco Sarebbe stato
universalmente riconosciuto e apprezzato
anche da quelle colleghe giornaliste che
mi dicevano di non parlarci troppo
per questo motivo vi dico non Rischiate
di diventare invisibili
ascoltate il vostro istinto anche quando
gli altri vi diranno che state
sbagliando Io l'ho fatto ed è lì che ho
capito come in quel momento Volevo
scegliere il silenzio Ma il silenzio
degli altri io ho deciso di farlo 8 anni
fa
lanciandomi nel buio perché credevo
assolutamente in Chiara e in quello che
potevamo fare insieme Grazie alla nostra
complementarità che ancora oggi abbiamo
e da quel momento la mia vita è cambiata
da quel momento insieme
abbiamo deciso di fare rumore da quel
momento abbiamo deciso di spiegare a
tutti che la tanto ostracizzata blogger
questo è il suo primo post Blond Salad
in realtà era il simbolo della giovane
imprenditrice made in Italy e che lei
stava costruendo un modo inedito di fare
comunicazione e impresa e non lo dico io
insieme
abbiamo messo la porta Chi in quel
momento non credeva in noi e abbiamo
portato due società che avevano 5
dipendenti a diventare due aziende che
oggi impiegano quasi 60 persone che
insieme con il loro lavoro nel 2022
hanno generato un giro d'affari di 66
milioni di euro
[Applauso]
insieme abbiamo provato
a trasformare un'idea abbozzata su
questo PDF che conservo tipo cimelio
della vita
in un documentario
Chiara Ferragni opposti ricordo ancora
quando andavo in giro con quel PDF a
dire vogliamo fare un documentario e non
ci credevo neanch'io e poi è successo un
documentario che poi abbiamo
autoprodotto insieme a Re cinema e che
racconta la storia della Rivoluzione dei
social media esattamente nel momento in
cui noi stavamo vivendo quella
rivoluzione
un documentario che dopo un lungo iter è
stato ammesso alla 76esima edizione del
festival del cinema di Venezia quando
l'ho saputo era in vacanza mi ricordo
era agosto non ci credevo neanche io
perché era impossibile
un documentario che è andato nelle sale
e ha venduto 160 mila biglietti in soli
tre giorni battendo il record di
spettatori di sempre per un film evento
nella storia del cinema italiano
un risultato che a quel punto ci ha
fatto pensare vabbè dai allora forse
qualcuno che ci vuole ascoltare c'è
quindi forse abbiamo fatto bene a fare
rumore
ed è sicuramente un rumore che
era stato nelle mie orecchie e resta
ancora anche nel mio cuore e questo
rumore voglio farvelo ascoltare
[Musica]
ciao ciao ciao Chiara
[Applauso]
a questo punto qualcuno di voi oggi
potrebbe dirmi ma mo quindi l'applauso
l'abbiamo già fatto Bravo Ok però io vi
ringrazio del vostro applauso ma non
sono qui per per questo e per gli
applausi per i bravi e le pacche sulle
spalle ma oggi sono qui per provare a
ricordare ad ognuno di voi
che è giusto avere un sogno e che ancora
più giusto avere una voce e farla
sentire quella voce
quella voce dovevate dovete farla
sentire e dovete
ascoltare chi cosa dicono gli altri per
poter far sentire anche la vostra di
voce e non abbiate paura Qual è il punto
emotivo dal quale State partendo e non
avete paura non avrete paura di Qual è
il luogo geografico dal quale State
partendo
Io sono partito da questo punto emotivo
sempre io a 4 anni timido parlavo con
nessuno Avevo quasi paura
Io sono partito da questo luogo
geografico venivo sempre qui al cinema
[Applauso]
venivo sempre qui al cinema d'estate e
mi sedevo sul prato qui di fuori con
l'amica la mia amica Alessia che è
seduta qui da qualche parte e sapete
essere proprio qui dove questa storia è
iniziata è una incredibile chiusura di
un cerchio
e non è una coincidenza se voi siete qui
a fare parte di questa chiusura
perché questa storia possa essere lo
spunto per scrivere nuove storie le
vostre storie
Questa è la storia del mio silenzio che
si è voluto trasformare il rumore per
inseguire l'istinto e scoprire quale
fosse il mio talento in complementarità
con quello di Chiara Ferragni Questa è
la storia di due voci Anzi ormai 60 voci
Unite per farsi forza perché insieme si
è sempre più forti Questo è il percorso
di due ragazzi arrivati a Milano dalla
provincia senza conoscere nessuno e
senza sapere nemmeno da dove cominciare
questo percorso ci insegna che se vuoi
puoi farlo anche tu e questa non è
retorica Perché oggi qui la mia storia
racconta proprio questo
questa storia la storia di quel bambino
di 4 anni chiuso in se stesso la dedico
a chi sentendosi inadeguato sceglie il
silenzio a patto però che trovi la voce
per gridare al mondo chi è veramente E
chi vuole diventare questa storia la mia
storia di quel bambino di 4 anni
voglio dedicarla a tutti voi che oggi in
silenzio mi avete ascoltato a patto che
usciti di qui Vi ricordiate di non
rinunciare a essere voi stessi
di non rinunciare a farvi ascoltare
anche se dovrete fare rumore Grazie
[Applauso]